arrey iteration I'm going to go through
eight methods to iterate through an
array to iterate means that you're going
through the array and you're doing
something with each item of the array
some some methods don't necessarily go
through each item but we'll get to that
most do the first one is for each maybe
show you an example here so you can see
in the example I'm passing in the array
one two three four each and for each is
pretty straightforward it just does
something for each item in the array so
we pass in we can pass on the item and
we pass in the index of the item of the
array and then for each in this example
for each item we're just going to cancel
the log and the index so if I run that
we can look in the console one zero two
one three two that's just the item in
the index the next way to iterate is map
in map it takes the item that's from the
array it does something to it and then
puts a new thing back in that same place
in the array so if we have this array
called three and there just says one two
three and now we are going to assign it
to doubled three that map that's how
we're going to iterate and we're going
to return the item times two it's just
going to double each item so instead of
the array being one two three there's
gonna be a new thing in place of each
item in the array I run that you can see
at the bottom two four six it's all been
doubled next up is filter filter is
gonna take an array and it's gonna check
each item in the array it gets again
some kind of condition to see if it's
true or false
if it's true it's going to put the item
back in the array if it's false it's not
going to put the item in the array and
each of these makes a brand new array so
we're going to pass in the numbers one
two three
it's filter and the condition is item
modulus two equals equals equals zero
and for each of these items is going to
check to see if if that's true and this
is just a way to find out even numbers
so if we run this you can see the bottom
of the console here
the only item is going to put
back into the array or into the return
array is too it doesn't actually put it
back into the array because ants
still eat is one two three but evens is
now to reduce and reduce we're going to
take an array and we're going to do
something and then pass the result to
the next iteration along with the next
item in the array so that's why we're
gonna put rid result in an item in here
so the first time it goes through the
array it's going to have a result and
it's going to send that result to the
next item to the next iteration and then
add an item the number at the end is
what the initial result is going to be
if you don't put a number at the end
like this the initial result will be the
first item in the array so when it goes
through this it's the result is going to
be zero then we're going to add the
first item that's one and then it's
gonna go through the item of the array
again and the result is now one and it's
going to I add the item two so one plus
two is three and this goes gonna go
through again there's all this three
it's gonna add three and that's gonna be
six and before we run that I'm gonna put
console.log sum and let's see at the
very end we get six next up is some some
you just check if any item in the array
so here's here's all the items in the
array
he has negative numbers sum means does
any item in the entire array meet this
condition so if any item in the entire
array meets the condition is less than
zero it's going to be true if no items
meet the condition then it's going to be
false so you can see this is true
because one of the items in the array is
negative the next one is every and this
is kind of similar to some but now every
number has to meet the condition so if
the Const all positive numbers we pass
in one two and three every now here's
the callback function we're gonna run
this function we're gonna pass in each
item if each
is more than zero then we're gonna put
true but also if we make just one item
negative when we run that we're gonna
have false so it's either all or nothing
with this one okay next one we're gonna
look at is find find goes through every
item in the array and checks it against
the condition and if that's true it
returns that item so it's searching for
a specific item in the in the array
if we pass in this array and in this
array we have a list of key value pairs
ideas a ideas B idea see objects that
fine will get passing this function with
the item so go through each item and
check to see if the ID equals equals
equals B and then if it finds that it's
going to return it so it returned the
whole thing ID B if it doesn't find your
item then it will return undefined and
the last one is find index find index is
pretty much just like find everything in
this code is the same except we just add
the word index here and instead of find
its find index and then we're canceling
find index so instead of returning the
actual item it's going to return the
index of the item so this is index 0 and
X 1 and X 2 and you can see that we're
looking for B and that's index 1 so if I
run that and you look at the bottom of
the console you will see a 1 if it does
not find the index anywhere it will
return negative 1 well thanks for
watching and special thanks to Jordan
Harve and I use something that he wrote
as inspiration for this video and you
can see the link to that in the
description don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good